my job is to head up the media relations
unit and to head up a team of press
officers and their task is really to
ensure that journalists here those who
are credited here in Brussels have all
the support that they need to be able to
cover and report on the activities of
the council and the European Council it
is a huge amount of work there are 13
professor price officers and they're all
fully occupied all the time and it's
particular case when we have major
meetings such as that of the European
Council if you look behind me you see at
the moment many empty chairs we will be
filled up later on with more than a
thousand journalists I am the press
officer responsible for the justice and
Home Affairs Council here we are with
the hectic preparations of the justice
and Home Affairs Council that we took
place this week at the end of the week
so we have prepared a document a
background briefing note for the
journalists so it's the document they
may use to write all the articles before
the council in a few minutes we will
hold a technical briefing and then they
can ask questions to the ambassador of
the residency and also we will help them
to understand what are the main issues
at stake in this meeting my name is
Alexandria kalencom and I coordinate
social media for the council we use
social media to communicate about our
work to answer questions and to monitor
emerging new stories and hot topics on
Twitter we're currently active on
Twitter Facebook YouTube and will
probably be branching out into Google+
as well
welcome to the media monitoring
Department we monitor the news in order
to be able to compile press reviews for
example this is one of ours it is a
compilation of all the articles of the
daily news from the main newspapers but
also in order to provide media in-depth
analysis for users for example the press
summary which gives a summary of the hot
topics of the day but we also write
media intelligence reports for example
this one that focuses on one specific
topic we mainly cover the written press
but our outcome has become almost
exclusively digital our role as the
press center is to organize all the
press events taking place here in the
council building this goes from press
conferences doorsteps at the VIP
entrance and of course all the
activities of the President of the
European Council and we also try to
ensure good working conditions for the
press whenever they come to the council
building this goes from organizing
workspace as this one here and providing
technical equipment such as Wi-Fi signal
is no the montrose example diluted I say
concert Finney County the Sun get a big
iki francophones applies Kelly chef data
yeah well haciendo tarea de perfil poco
de on Cooper zeros on Sheila proceed on
Wilshire may San Sarah Palin on
applicants area on a la foto Austrian
the group data by crc benefit
what we are doing here with the
audiovisual team of the council is that
we are responsible for covering all the
public part of the events that are
happening here which means concretely
that we are everywhere with cameras
we're with photographers we capture the
right moments we digitize everything and
we upload it on a platform that we call
TV in useful and all these people here
behind me they are actively working now
on uploading all the material that we
have been filming today in order for
journalists to be able to download the
material very quickly and to republish
it on their channels or their platforms
and we try to do that really in no type